today I'm joined by Rafi Tross who
recently won the seti forward award from
the set Institute welcome to the show
Rafi good to be here Martin Rafi the
city forward award is about seti search
for extraterrestrial intelligence right
that's right together with my advisor
Steve Croft I searched radio frequency
data from the Green Bank telescope in
West Virginia to find radio techno
signatures and I use Google Cloud to do
it excellent can't wait to hear more
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you said techno signatures what does
that mean right so it's a distinguishing
between natural emission sources and
artificial sources natural sources being
stars or galaxies or anything out there
in space and artificial being from a
technological civilization like Earth
got it uh it's my understanding that a
Galaxy can generate a lot of radio noise
and collapsing black holes and quasars
and things and they can be very loud and
so how do you pick out these weak
artificial leaked signals from this sea
of very loud natural radio noise yeah
it's a good question so natural signals
we expect them to be spread out in
frequency but not stay around for very
long but technological artificial signal
signals we expect to be very narrow in
frequency but stay around for a long
time because their Tech their
communication signals so we'd expect
them to stick around a lot longer
looks like frequency is on the x-axis
and time is on the y-axis I feel my old
math classes may become useful again
so if we can do a Fourier transform on
the radio noise we can see if any
frequencies stick out
that's right in principle that should be
perfect like in the books but it's a
little bit more complicated than that
there's lots of signals from Earth like
Bluetooth Wi-Fi GPS anything that we get
from space looks exactly similar to all
the signals that we want to get from
extraterrestrial civilizations
all right so is it possible to filter
out all that Bluetooth and GPS and all
that
yes it is but my first thought would
have been that you can filter them out
based on what they look like in the
graphs but
like I said before they are almost
identical so we have to go by different
means and that's by we do this by
changing how the telescope looks at the
object and so we observe in a way in
which we look at the target of Interest
then we look away from it and we try to
localize which signals are from space
and which ones are for murder
got it so in the top panel here we're
looking at the Target star and then in
the second panel we look away from the
star
and the idea is that microwaves and
garage door openers and all that stuff
that will appear regardless of whether
we look at the store or away from it
that's right so the telescope is only in
one position it can't move and whatever
signals from Earth are hitting it right
now are probably going to be hitting it
at later time too and so we can
reasonably expect that all the signals
that are that we see when we're not
looking at the Target will stay there
for that throughout the entire
observation got it and a minute ago you
said that this was simulated data do you
have any real telescope data that you
can show us certainly so here are three
plots that we have of real telescope
beta the leftmost one shows a signal
that's pretty coherent throughout the
whole thing
and so we can reasonably deduce that
this is most definitely terrestrial
because it shows up in all the
observations in the middle one we can
see that it's not very coherent and this
is an artifact of our signal processing
software Turbo seti and this is an
artifact of it because it's clearly not
a coherent signal like the first one and
so this is just a problem with turbo
seti this is an example of where the
program does exactly what we tell it to
do but not exactly what we wanted to do
um on the right side is another example
of terrestrial interference and it's
because of the certain
and we expect certain terrestrial
sources to look like these and graphs
and so we just identify it as into as
terrestrial interference
go audit that makes sense uh I think I
get the theory now uh but how does all
this work in practice uh how do you
actually get the data from the radio
telescope yes so the telescope that's
thing it looks at the sky we collect the
data we save the data in three different
formats for three different interesting
science projects and so I look at the
find frequency resolution data products
and this data is in filter Bank format
and these files are each on order of
gigabytes and for certain targets the
telescope uploads that data to a Google
Cloud Storage bucket and then people
like me come along who want to process
this data and we go into Google cloud
and we operate on the buckets themselves
and and how does that work the the files
are in Google cloud storage and uh what
do these files actually contain
yeah these files contain anything that
landed on the telescope any Photon that
landed on the telescope while we were
observing
um and so the radio sky is pretty full
and it's pretty noisy but there's a
certain section of radio frequencies
that is actually pretty quiet at and so
we observe at these frequencies and this
is around 1 to 11 gigahertz
and so each filter Bank file contains
all the data we find
well we're observing that and each file
has a resolution of three Hertz because
we're looking for a narrow band signal
so three Hertz resolution is pretty good
for what we're going to be looking for
got it so now these files are on Google
Cloud how did you process them yes so I
used virtual machines from Google Cloud
platform I installed on each of them the
program that we use turbo study and then
pointed each of these virtual machines
to different files in the bucket they do
their thing they process for about a
week
and tell process about 58 hours of
telescope data and which a week sounds
like a long time but it's much faster
than previous studies had got it so the
limit here is not actual radio
telescopes it's a computing power yes so
that's what makes Google Cloud platform
that much more interesting so we can
process a lot more data uh than if we
would have done it just on disk on your
regular laptops and such right okay so
you run the turbo 30 software on this
data for a week uh what what is the
output of the software yes the software
goes through each of these filtering
files that we're talking about and
searches for hits which are signals
above a signal noise ratio of 10. it's
arbitrary that we choose 10 but previous
Studies have also chosen 10 so it makes
comparing our results that much easier
and so we expect that a lot of these
hits are terrestrial interference and
not anything of Interest
got it uh did you get any hits uh that
weren't obviously for Marth uh I really
wanted to
um I didn't get any hits but uh you'd be
the most famous person in world history
if you did I know I know
um yeah but during the summer internship
uh there was an intern who did find
something pretty interesting on the
different telescope and different data
and I remember the meeting it was it was
pretty cool to watch because uh he just
comes up and says I think I found
something and like it's all everyone
freezes every all the experts are
huddling close to cameras trying to get
a really good look at what they're
looking at and then everyone just goes
on to a different call because we need
to figure out what this thing is is this
what is this and it turned out that
Unfortunately they ruled it out
um from being what we wanted to be in
extra intelligence
um but it did actually start a good
like how are we going to what do we do
what if we find the signal that we can't
explain
you're right I mean yeah in the movies
it's all a conspiracy theory and it's
very cut and dry but I guess in real
life it's not so simple yeah I wish it
was like the movies that's it's much
simpler
so what do you think is next for seti
yeah so it's a pretty exciting field
right now there's still a lot of Sky to
look at and we see well on this graph
here this is just the sample of stars
that we believe we have good evidence to
suspect that they host Earth-like
exoplanets which inherently make them
interesting uh steady targets and so the
red ones are the ones that I looked at
and all the blue ones are ones that we
haven't looked at and this is an ongoing
study so that's I'm excited to see the
results of that there's also searching
the Million nearby Stars there's also
searching 123 nearby galaxies so it'll
be the first search for extra Galactic
Civilization and stuff so I'm excited to
see those results
wow and what are your personal goals
Rafi after now that you've wrapped up
this project yeah my personal goals are
so I'm going to be starting graduate
school for a master's program uh at
DePaul University and after that I'm
hoping to enroll in some sort of PhD
program but as a career goal I want to
help the Philippines so I was adopted
when I was two and grew up in the US and
all my life I've wanted to somehow give
back and the way I can give back is
somehow using my expertise that I hope
to gain and so I hope to help the
Philippine space agency which was
founded like like four years ago so I
hope to help them with their natural
disaster monitoring and other
space-based assets that will improve the
quality of life cool thanks for joining
me on the show Rafi can't wait to see
what uh what you do and what happens
with extraterrestrial intelligence and
your personal aspirations well thank you
thank you for having me and thank you
everyone for watching if you have any
questions for Rafi or me please let us
know in the comments and if you have any
requests for cloud computing topics we
should bring up in future episodes
please also let us know below I read
every single comment until next time
[Music]
thank you